[applause
] i would like to welcome you to
friedrich nietzsche, one of the very
great european philosophers and
today we are dealing with the famous will
to power and his very great
vision of the superman
and you will see nietzsche has
rich thoughts that are downright
burning  are up-to-date and he
already wrote down and formulated a very small sentence in 1855
which he
went around the world it is
very short i brought you
god is dead
and this little sentence
is known everywhere nowadays even about him
so not only  in europe also in america
god is
dead i have heard
that before very few people know that this sentence comes
from nietzsche but it is only known that it spread
around the
world like wildfire because
nietzsche got to the heart of something that was
actually in  the next
centuries the entire world the
entire western hemisphere the
western  world should become a
problem and by god is dead
nietzsche does not mean just any event that
god suddenly died but
a process he says what i tell
is the story of the next two
centuries
i describe what is coming what can no longer
come otherwise
the origin of the  nihilism so what he
tells is god is dead
means it's about the history of the next
two centuries 18 50 rum
said that if you extrapolate 19.50 2050
that's a process that goes back to our
time and it's the process of the
emergence of nihilism and  of mass
atheism and if we are honest
up
to half a million people actually leave the
churches every year even in the luther year there are
numerous appearances and one has to
assume that in just a few years
the majority of the
european population will no longer be in
of the church
and seen in this way, his prediction was of
course quite precise  the reason why
that happened said are on the one hand
the emerging
natural sciences you have to consider
6:50 pm contemporary of nietzsche was
charles darwin who was the first to say
we are not all descended from adam and
eve but we are higher mammals
that evolved via the apes
about the hominids slowly
arose and it was not only because of this
numerous scientists have made the
old religious world view in which
we were safe for thousands of years to
shake and break it is
also so it was a crazy start
in medicine in physics everywhere and
to  example in medicine, too
, people used to think of the plague cholera, these
serious diseases in particular the
plague, it is the work of the devil or
it is a punishment from god, but even before
1900, for example, russian
scientists said no, it is
just a bacterial infection
and everything was attributed to the
put to the test there were there  times was a very
big awakening and more and more
doubts were raised not only about adam and eve
about the virginal conception about the
whole story of the creator, in the
end also about god himself
and now nietzsche says where is
god
and then something exciting is coming we have
him  killed yours and i we are all
his murderers and what he means by that is
quite simple it wasn't just darwin
and the scientists who
killed god with their
theories explaining the new world no
we were all because we withdrew god's
giving power from designs because  we
no longer believed in him like that
nietzsche was the first postmodern
think so he was too he even writes
a book that means the antichrist so
yes bicycle is a convinced atheist but
he was also the first
postmodern thinker why postmodern what
does postmodern mean what does one mean then  so
we generally understand the modern age as
this great awakening of the
enlightenment  n when the
natural sciences began when
suddenly the french enlighteners
russo voltaire
montesquieu called for a separation of powers yes who
should rule the people if i the people
and so on
that was a great awakening the
enlightenment and the enlightenment
elimination the french say the the
the the enlightenment the  Illumination of the
light of reason should reach everywhere
and should, so to speak, illuminate and enlighten superstition,
belief, myth and
the old world views
that was modern miet is
the first postmodern thinker it is
not enough for him to say that this
enlightenment was also very critical
kant  lure all the enlighteners
were also criticism of religion but it is
not enough that to criticize he
says yes the actual question that
man has to ask himself in the next
centuries is a completely different one
what happens when the last
man has turned to god  believe what
happens then what  interested him
yes and then he just says quote since
the belief has ceased that a god determines
the fate of the world on a large
scale people have to face the
whole world with exciting goals
here lies the tremendous task so
if we are no longer safe in  the
religious world view that life is a
task that we have to fulfill in order to get
to paradise if it can no
longer carry us then we have to
take on this task ourselves people
now have to set themselves
global
goals that span the entire earth in order to shape the future  and
now he says
and that's why he's also considered a
postmodern thinker we have a big
problem says people aren't
ready for it
because his contemporaries he says when
he looks at it he can only
shake his head they
hardly fall for the fact that god is dead
false idols and  new
idols are erected one of these idols
says it is nationalism and this  e
whole Germanism it started back
then we are you 18 70 the
founding of the empire and everything was like that at the
time said the Germanism gets
on his nerves so much
and if there is a people at all that can be
proud of being patriotic
be proud of their culture  may be
then the french
and then he says there is
some thought behind this
horned cattle nationalism what value
could it have now that everything points to
larger and common interests to
incite these rough feelings
themselves and it always
annoyed him these branches created the
thinking movements  these marching
things the fuss with the emperor
that got on his nerves
says that's just a new idol god is
dead we no longer have meaning
through religion now let's
give ourselves meaning by saying we
are germans or by saying we  say we are
french or english and that is
wrong
the next big idol says e  r and
it's even worse that people
now want to get their self-esteem after god is
dead from the fact that they are
higher than others and because of that they can
still feel a little bit important even in the age of
nihilism
and that's where the
racists are always looking  some group in the
case of the antisemites and he says
down the antisemites
don't forgive the jews that the jews have brains
and take money the antisemitism who got off
badly
there is no outrageous honor and
stupid federal government in germany
after all antisemites are the main niche
scolds a lot but the
anti-
semites of the had been friends with wagner for a while
before of course they fell
out and wagner also writes that
lately it's
unbearable this constant anti-semit
3er is almost as bad as my
sister and because that was  deeply
repugnant because he says god is dead
now we have to get out  create ourselves and
it can't be that we have
a sense of self-worth, too.
you can see that nietzsche was
anything but a nazi. any appropriation
for this direction is not possible in
view of these statements by nietzsche
and the only thing that hitler really had from
nietzsche  and was
able to take over one to one was
nietzsche's original walking stick he gave it to hitler
after the table and death was the
sister of niger gave him this
walking stick but
he almost certainly didn't read it well at all
then he says it
's another great idol now
even since he
might play a role in the next few centuries he is
incredibly far-sighted politically and he
says it is the socialism of
socialism you know 1848 karl marx
communist manifesto then of
course noticed this movement
even though there was not a single
socialist state but his
prognosis was back then  already negative he
says  socialism desires an abundance
of state power such as every
despotism has had, yes, it surpasses
everything that has gone before by striving for the
formal annihilation of the individual
and it drives the
half-educated masses the word
justice like a nail into the
head in order to rob them completely of their
reason
So he also criticized socialism as a
new idol because he says they are
striving for a despotic state authority
, then only the party governs and
the party is always right and
all
individuals are brought into line and said socialism
cannot work because of the human being
not the same we are not all the
same and
individualism was very important to nietzsche in particular and he says
if we all give everyone the same amount of money
right away it can’t
go well and this abolition of the
individual will take revenge
but that’s why socialism is for him too
a new religion he says
yes good g  ott is dead
now people no longer believe that they will
go to paradise what do you
promise them a workers' paradise
and give a worldly promise of salvation
instead of the metaphysical
promise of salvation which
work no longer says is
also bad if you stick to these
idols and the fourth great
idol ladies and gentlemen what will the
other be it is the one
we believe in today yes, capitalism
quote the traders ask
for supply and demand in everything that is created in
order to determine the value of an item
this is a characteristic of an entire
culture  done that's what your
people will be proud of in the next century of
course it's also crass world back
then the validation of capitalism was
already there in the beginnings but not
yet developed that much but he says the driver of
action the businessman
or the capitalist or entrepreneur
is crap  everything only afterwards what the  true
leading value has on the market according to
supply and demand of the rented
apartment as expensive as it is somehow possible
that he still finds tenants or sells
them and everything is only determined according to supply
and demand there are no
other principles of justice
anymore and after that next to all  and there
is a new idolatry
people will only be
judged by how much they have achieved, how
rich they are and so on and offer
money to the wretched Mammon and it is
just as much idolatry to god
as socialism and nationalism
and these idols  that's why we don't have a
chance said niki because they comfort us
because it's not easy to endure
nilism the cold breath of nihilism
after death is over
we console each other and now he asks the question
how how do we console the murderers
murderers we don't have to do it ourselves  to be done
that's the central question now that's
a postmodern question
how are things going jet  still after
god has lost his power to create science
and fewer and fewer people
go to church and get their whole
world view from it how does it
go on how do we console the murderers of
everyone he wants and we don't
have to become gods ourselves and here
his answer is a clear yes we have
to take the fate of this world
into our
own hands now we have to take on this great task now the
only problem is
that's why the idols are conjured up again and
again we are not yet
in a position to say that's enough  not
yet we don't have the
strength to take on this task but we
have to get there because all gods are dead
now we want the superman to
live and we
will deal with that now what is this
superman where should we go according to
nietzsche but you  see how
up-to-date that actually is, so he
's already close, that's why he's
the postmodern one, I think  t already at the
age of 25 as a young guy nietzsche found
the key to understanding
the whole world thinks he has
discovered it and we are you where he
found this key
in the old greek
tragedy of all places
he says these old numbers these old
greek tragedies the  have recognized
what being human and what the whole
world essentially means because in
these old tragedies there are always only
two major principles i.e. the hero who
fights and powers and is
always torn between the dionysian
and the apollinian principle i
have  90 act he says
there are two states in which the
art, i.e. the theater itself, appears like a force of
nature in the human being, once
as a compulsion to vision, on the other hand as a
compulsion to orgasm lower the saying
in each of us now not only
in the 3
Greek holds  antiquity but also in
each one of us there are two principles
which are briefly one  the
apollinian principle that he calls here
the one of compulsion to vision
so we want to have visions we
want to plan the world we want to
shape the world that he calls the
apollinian principle after the god
apollo apollon greek god was the
god of planning the future also
the god of prophecy  reason he was
the radiant god of cities founding
it was in a word a maker
we would say today but also a thinker who
planned and structured so the
apollinian principle stands for
rational planning in people but
at the same time there is also knowing
dionysus  probably all the good
god of intoxication i.e. god of wine
not of intoxication of wine yes
secondary to intoxication if you overdo it
and dionysus also has of
course he also stands for
creativity for the chaotic for the
purely emotional for the passion
it becomes passionate knowledge
the illustrations he is always with
women un  d wine and these two
principles fight against each other in every human being
and also in the
classic tragedy
so it is often the case that we
plan and do something and at the last
moment we do it differently than for
some reason we know that
who is sensible now  and what we do is
and from the film we make it
and so you have to imagine that the
political always first tries
to shape the world and it brings the
tunisian back to dancing
always tries to do everything right and
comes to town and there is a
despotic king and then he fights
with the kills the one who fell in love with the
queen married and at some point he
realizes that he
has fallen in love with his own mother, he even knew that
not because he was exposed as children and
then of
course everything is in chaos again
so they have to understand each other and never said
but that's life
the churches have recognized how our
life really is and we need the
amor fati the love of fate and
that means that we
never completely get out of suffering but we have
to accept these two principles that
's normal but already in ancient times
a big mistake has now
been made
with euripides, such a dramaturge, suddenly the dionysian aspect was simply gone,
suppressed, no
longer considered, because in
classical tragedy there was always
a
chorus, the lamentation chorus, they always portrayed the feelings and the dionysian aspect
and what was on the stage
was the apollinian for me and at the latest
under europe the chorus was left out
the dionysian played less and less of a role
the rational human being
became stronger and stronger in antiquity and with
plato and his main character it
went even further there  it was
suddenly said that Dionysian is bad and
evil we have to
orient ourselves upwards  eren the idea of the justice of th
true of the beautiful and sudde
ly being human was completely redefined happi
ess says nietzsche just means you have
o imitate sokratis and creat
a daylight against the dark incursions the d
ylight of reason every yield
ng to the instincts to the uncon
cious leads us  down and he
says never what happens a spirit body
separation of the bodily the dionysian
our lust our sensuality is evil that
leads down the spirit the reason
that understood there it leads us up and
that was a very
bad development because of fate because that's what he
puts it  then even the moralism of
the greek philosophers from plato
onwards is pathological and it becomes even more sick and
pathological with the
emergence of christianity because
christianity now has a much
greater body hostility i do
n't know which of them was raised catholic after all
we are in bavaria  I still
learned in D  he puberty you shouldn't
think unchastely
yes what of course no
one can really try now yes and never said
with christianity it then became quite
fatal because in
antiquity there were orphans and
fools under wise has the soul
upwards  developed and the goal just
followed his solved and soy says the
plate and is the existence of a duck is
and [ __ ] and is happy about it
but in christianity how they got
worse because in christianity there
is bipolarity there is good and
bad and  one can just as well deal with evil and
the devil without
developing and the body the
physical body the temptation of
the future belongs to the abbot yes and now
criticized christianity for four
reasons firstly i condemn
christianity i surrender to the
christian church the most terrible of
all  systems that an accuser has ever put into his
mouth
it is it has a worthlessness from every value
from every wah  rheit made a
lie with that meant in his
explanations also led to the the
whole symbol this god on the cross
this jesus the suffering everything has been
lost that is actually
important for us humans namely also the
courage to fight
heroically standing up
that's just the  also the one on the left and
said that's that was that was a mistake
that was a mistake second said
compassion is not good either what
christianity propagates so to speak
compassion says it is a waste
of feelings in the moral
health-damaging parasite it ca
n't possibly duty  be the evils in the
world to lose because very often he says
we do out of pity
give alms and prolong everything possible because of
the suffering of the people who might otherwise
rebel and what would do to
change society no we
feed everyone and this pity
solves  no problems and pity says
he may be showing contempt
be when you get pity from someone
so pity is something really bad for him
is by the way also times the
beggars should get rid of if you
always feel bad when you
walk past the beggar either give me
something you feel really bad
or you don't give him anything  if you also give yourself
important ones so sorry that was
n't for him then the third big
criticism of christianity he says
a whole new breed of people is being
created now he says maybe there has
n't been a more dangerous ideology no
greater nonsense in psychology than this
will to the good  man raised the
most disgusting type of unfree
man neckermann taught
just as a mother you are on the right
path to the deity you know in
christianity humility is very important
and because it is constantly committed to the
good and because life is
a test a task  is and he
says in the end a book often comes
out and it is not only true for the
c  christianity so you know it doesn't matter if
now in islam there is also prayer
and the ground bows down to the
ground or the christians who kneel down
he says there comes a strange
crowd of people that he doesn't think is
healthy and that's the last thing he
criticizes  is if your eye
trouble travel it out the
christ who followed that advice and
thinks he has killed his sensuality is mistaken it
lives on in a weird vampiric way
and torments him in disgusting
disguises so he says it
doesn't work that easy either that
we  only live apolitically and is
completely suppressing Dionysian because
and then he anticipates something, by the way, which
later sigmund freud says the
entire psychology but also
specifically psychoanalysis fundamentally also says
the desires our desire our
companies and also the great desires in life
that we suppress they are
not  just gone but the smolder
and can even against u
so many
neurotic diseases are attributed
to the fact that people had
to suppress too many of their
wishes in life for too long
and he says that is also dangerous
about this christian ideology as
he calls it
overall this big one bothers him too
sorry hostility because we
already know since he was 25
everyone is also a musician and that's why he
says he stays, i'm nothing at
all, besides that, i'm
he wants that kind of hostility towards the
whole tradition, including philosophy, they
say we do too  are primarily
rational beings in it sometimes rational and
the body is the servant of
the spirit that only carries out what the spirit
decides so it's not
nietzsche talking about the great
reason of the body because said it would
also be a complete illusion to believe
that our reason  we are governed by our
consciousness because there is, by the way,
today's science  people have been confirming it scientifically for
an insanely long time
we would have to say life has existed
for about three billion years
so three billion is hard to
imagine and
the hominids matches also speaks of the half-animals they
've been around forever but they
were in the forests in hordes and
he has no consciousness
and only at the very end in the history of
evolution did
consciousness arise at all,
but we still have this heritage in
us and that is why it cannot be taken away
he says then you were once apes
and also now  man is still more
than any ape yes it is this
this tendency that has but how did
it come to this when we billions of years have
only lived instinctively instinct yes according to stimulus
and reaction and lust
including unicellular organisms and the whole
evolution like you  because come that
today we have something like that at all, we have an
awareness and even worse a
bad  htes conscience and he wrote this
famous chapter in the genealogy of
morals about the emergence
of a bad conscience and he
says that the whole madness arose at the moment
when people left the forests
and only
just founded communities and villages and
then states were also founded within
these communities and
something bad started to happen there were
laws and rules
and now no one was allowed
to do anything to anyone but you had to let go of
all your previous instincts that you
had the anger the attention the
aggression the work is you  in the
forest you could still hear every cracking
you could smell
it you knew now i had to run
if you were threatened or if you were
attacked while hunting
we were instinctively sure he says we lost all our instincts we used to have
the whole development  evolution is
negative water carried us earlier
than  o we were in the water
now our feet have to carry us and that
was also a very negative step when
suddenly the consciousness was given up by
the green states and by the
founding of the state yes because he says all
of a sudden all their
instincts were devalued and posted up i
believe that never  events on earth there was
such a feeling when
suddenly the instincts were devalued
and you know it is actually the case the
instincts are devalued and not only
devalued they are taboo so when
i get the choleric attack here at work
and my
brothers and you get angry  are then
everyone would say they are aggressive but because
i'm still here but you can't
live it anymore these instincts are
unhooked and devalued and now in the
state when we lived in such large groups
together
then it was about something else these
people so  they were now on think
close calculate combine
causes and effects reduzi  ert
these unfortunate ones on their consciousness
on their poorest and misguided
organ so all of a sudden we were
dependent on our poor organ on
our consciousness and thought on the market
calculated calculated
then we used to
be instinctively sure for many years throughout evolution
and now we have
loss of this instinct yes now what
happened there said all instincts that
don't vent outwards
turn inwards told exciting he says
because we can't be aggressive
anymore we can't even
take food if you're
hungry make small children  it's also still in the store
if you don't guard the shopping
trolley then the turnips grab them they want to make
the chocolate and eat it
works it's instinctive they
have to learn later of course that
all this isn't possible and we know it we act
all our instincts inwards
and flatly  all of these just about the
aggression  For thousands of years
aggression saved us because we defended territory
conquered new things
because we moved in the horde
and now it is against
ourselves because we have to suppress it
and this energy that is
being directed inward now leads to self-
tightening impulses and  that is the
origin of the bad conscience
so he says here the enmity the
cruelty the desire to be pursued
the attack the change the destruction
everything that turns against the owner of such
instincts
that is the origin of the bad
conscience the punishments said do the
rest  that we know of course
if we don't follow the rules of the
state we will be punished but in the
end our bad conscience is
also fed by our own energy
that we know we should
n't now and keep ourselves in
check with our own energy and the
quintessence  now both consciousness
and conscience are ga  nz late phenomena
in the evolution is
is not there at all
and ultimately not allowed to play the
decisive role in our
lives but the decisive
factor is nietzsche that we
still have and we feel that in us
an enormous will we have
wishes we  have longings we have
needs and he doesn't just mean
eating and drinking he says all the
needs longings wishes that
we have that he gives our will
every human being has wanted to be and
now we're at the core chapter already the
will to power he says
this world a monster without beginning
without end is the will to power and
nothing but that and also you yourself
since this will to power and nothing else
how can he claim this
world a monster of power up to the
will to power the world is really
the will  to power he says the
whole world is the will to power
and that's because every plant
grows after the  sun that gets
shaded partly other plants that
then also stretch and
make themselves but when small trees have
big ones mostly small ones die or
that it grows faster so
there is also an unconditional will to
live, to survive and to
improve
oneself  with plants and even in
chemistry he says if you know substances mission
you still hate
chemistry class then it was 40 that they
react with each other either
they mix or they repel
each other but in any case nietzsche says
forces act like they act in nature as a whole
forces that's why he says is a monster
of power can nature also the
planets there is also a nice
sentence that the supposed laws of nature
are nothing more than
relations of forces so that the
planets attract each other and these
orbits have that is exactly
calculated from how much force of attraction the
has one on the other and so it
commutes from there g  it's also about strength
and with people anyway he
also has an interesting example of the
first living beings is at that
time there were also then by means of
groups and duties they could
enlarge optically and then he
says the the amoeba of the smallest little animal
it also has little hairs and the
working forum sees it as soon as the seagull encounters something
organic,
and if it wins it over
, the india furniture is integrated,
so it’s open, so to speak, and
we’ve had this appropriation in nature since the beginning
will to power and we
ourselves as human beings we are nothing
other than this will to power and
that's why he says everything happened
wheels can be reduced to
the intention of increasing power but that's happening
now but said that we always
affect others too  increasing
our power can also mean that
we hinder others in their own self-
improvement
yes and that's where you get off  he doesn't stand
around that's why he says life always lives
at the expense of other lives who
hasn't understood that i haven't yet taken
the first step towards honesty
he says we can't help it so
if you apply
for some department head job and
get the dummy  Colleagues don't apply,
the lowly ones just don't apply and are then
sad, so every success often comes
at the expense of the failure of others
or the olympic champion who then stands at the
top of the protest with the winner's wreath
radiant golden in the glory of victory who
stands up there because he has other people at the same time
darkens and seals that off are
not up there that's why we ca
n't live at all without affecting others
doesn't stand he says and then he also has
more subtle examples that i
find very exciting he has, for example, i
when two love the same charming woman
and fall in love with her or
even three and one gets them because
two others stay behind or  also
one of his most subtle example
years was also a great psychologist
he says mothers an early early childhood
phase is something interesting for him
because he says mothers who let’s say
love one child more than the other or
the others at that time all had 56 of them
they don't do it consciously they are
fair they give everyone the same amount
but they can't help it one
thing is somehow closer to them and the worst thing is he says the children feel they feel this and that being and
the mother this is not to blame he says
you have to  because finally think beyond good
and evil that's the title of one
of his books beyond good and
evil
the mother who loves the one child just a
bit more unconsciously she
can't really help it if
she tries to always be fair and
just  but the less loved child can
be feels neglected and
has a lot to do with it and that's why we
can't help but live always lives a  at the
expense of other life that's in
nature so that with us it's a
nice sentence the insects don't
bite out of malice but because they can also live with
it so the mosquitoes keep on with it
and it's all right but in
reality never what should you do
even if  it is malicious for us terrorists
but that they can't
help it and so we often can't
help it either and no one goes through life without
causing problems for others at some point
and because that's the way it is said
because we can't get out of it he says  i
appreciate the power of a will by
how much resistance pain ordeal
it endures and how to transform itself into an advantage
he said everyone has
resistance in life but we can use
resistance as an opportunity
to grow and
transform it into an advantage
that is our self-development our will
to the power he goes against resistance
always in life but he appreciates the level of the
individual according to whether the individual can
make it  to overcome the things that are against it
and to make one's
will now of course one can say
and for that he was also
criticized a lot for that that it is limitless that
he says clearly but if everyone then
lives their will to power yes there will
eventually be a huge one  out of egoism
everyone develops their will to power
and what limits should it have if
not even pity is a limit
if not even
pity limits our egoism
where is the limit of the will to power
one may overpower others one
may even allow others because of the
development  and killing one's own higher
purpose and he said that you it
can actually be now that comes
quite radical as well as radical thought
from nietzsche he says that anything a
hundred times it can be that it can
be it's possible for each of us
that anything is a hundred times more
important than  the question of whether we are well or
badly and consequently also whether
the others are well  or feel bad in
short that we have a goal for the
sake of which one does not hesitate to
make human sacrifices
so it can actually be that we are not allowed to
take witchte sacrifices into consideration for the development of our sixth goal and
our will to power, we neither
ourselves nor others
must also sacrifice human beings
, of course, quotes like this brought them close to
fascism and you
also know mussolini he never really
read them and had a huge memorial
erected for them and because of course he
knows no boundaries first of
all, but ladies and gentlemen, we do
try
to look at it non-ideologically without immediately
pushing him in any direction and
then it can actually be the case if you
're honest that sometimes you
push yourself for a higher goal, whether you
feel good or bad about it that
shouldn't play a role and  also
like the others much if necessary we have to
bring human sacrifices
just think of the former federal chancellor, former federal chancellor
helmut schmidt he
got into a very difficult one could
say tragic situation because
the baader meinhof group was imprisoned in some cases accused
several times it
is fashionable then the
terrorists who were still outside
hijacked a lufthansa plane and  the
employer president schleyer and
have just made an offer to
negotiate that they will all be released nothing will
happen to anyone but for that
rieti meinhof baader and the others in
this group must also be released
and helmut schmidt was faced with
this difficult
decision with his cabinet and he said no who
that didn't
let the lufthansa plane storm and
hanns martin schleyer was executed, so
to speak, killed by the
terrorists and that's crazy
schmidt even sat next to
this woman veil at
the funeral that was a really, really hard phase for him
I would say for days  he would  en
bring this sacrifice back yes so he has as
you can see here for a higher goal yes
so that we have a goal for the
sake of which one does not hesitate
to bring human sacrifices he had said this goal his
goal was the raison d'état more it
doesn't work the rule of law has to
condemn his perpetrators and
bring them to justice we can't
throw away our legal system when violence comes from outside
and say well
we'll let them go anyway if it's words
that might even kill again he
says no it's not possible the higher goal
is in that case the  the rule of law and
our justice must
take precedence over this release and he would basically sacrifice
hanns martin
schleyer again i didn't want to
sacrifice of course but he is aware of this
life he said he will do it again
and by the way he also wrote a
note a  Written who has
deposited that if he himself is
kidnapped or Loki Schmidt
his wife that  they were not
allowed
to be exchanged he had also deposited so he also made the
sacrifice for himself what
he now asked for or was it would have been
willing to make this sacrifice
so you can see how it can be
interpreted like that of
course nietzsche also has his will
to power  now not only extended to the
individual but also
said it also applies of course to large
peoples
also large peoples in history
have lived their will to power
which is nothing bad for nietzsche
he says for example those big
greenhouses for the strong for the strongest for
the strongest kind of human being  here comes
this strong and weak, which is why we
are also criticized a lot, those
big hothouses for the strong and for
the strongest kind of people that have existed so
far, the aristocratic
communities in the kind of rome and
venice understood freedom exactly in
the sense as i used the word
understand freedom as something that you have and that
you don't have there  ss you want to
conquer so there hovers in the space before
ancient rome and venice those were
communities that used their freedom and their
self-development to
conquer, to keep and
to gain what they don't have and
that's why mussolini yes  also found it
so great because he also wanted to revive
the old rome and these old splendours
, but we would
soon see that it wasn’t really about that, he also celebrates venice and if
we read on then said the
northern italian cities also have them  great
developed the will to power and i
'll tell you right now why he
says, by the way, in the renaissance at
that time when venice and later
florence and these northern
italian cities had this honorable power, mankind took
an enormous step
forward he even claims that
today
's european remains below
the renaissan european in terms of value  nce so they did
something great in the renaissance
and then it wasn't
his concern that venice controlled the entire mediterranean area with it's merchant fleet
, it
wasn't his concern that the borgia
ruled there, it was
essentially that in the
renaissance an enormous act of
self-liberation of man
found for the first time the
sciences flourished the doctors were
allowed to quote the same and
for the first time one was freed from
the millennia-old medieval
thinking so you know the
artists also had leonardo da
vinci or
michelangelo, for example, they were also  scientists who
had a completely free, enlightened way of
thinking and for the first time perspective was also
painted that is right in the
middle ages were only two-dimensional yes
and you could see the
haloes but that didn’t have any then it started with
the perspective then the whole
sciences are on the  that inspired him
or or the brother of the
bride because this is this huge dome
and in the renaissance
people liberated themselves and the artists,
by the way, first signed their works themselves
and they
suddenly painted beautiful naked bodies it
was a lot dionysian says he  the
renaissance when nudity was completely
forbidden in the middle ages and then of
course they did something, how should i put it, something
exciting the perpetrator is an
artist they simply said yes we
paint antique things like botticelli’s venus
and of course an
antique goddess venus has to be like that  being naked so
orderly and and he just liked this departure
so the Italian wrote
this for example no misprint it used to
be written like this the italian
renaissance park in sight the liberation
of thought the disregard for
authorities the victory of education over
the conceit of birth  enthusiasm
for science unleashing the
individual  duums a glow of truthfulness
so you see will to power does
not necessarily mean huge
conquests with nietzsche but ktc more also about
proximity spiritual development about an
artistic and further
and that brings us to our
initial question and to our last
big chapter how do you think it  yes,
how can we develop ourselves what
is this superhuman he us
deep down the gods are dead now we
want the superhuman to live who or what
is this superhuman and
can we maybe also become superhuman here in the hall
and  let's take a look at
that now
finally yes the superman says
nietzsche the superman is close to my
heart he
is my first and only thing and
not the man not the next not
the poorest not the one who suffers not
the best
and that's interesting  that
he says he is always
close to the heart about people and not about people and this
about people is just not d  he next
that is actually clear and also not
the first and not suffer
that is again what we already
know from nietzsche his how should i thanks
negative assessments of christian
heroes so the hero on the gold
because jesus on the cross is the suffering or
also the  poorest how should i thanks the
superman of religions is the
ascetic like and brother who
withdraws or just like jesus or
also the franciscans and numerous
mendicant orders they only had a rope
around the custom and had their customers
on there was this ideal of
refusal of any ownership of everything that was
music and that rejected so that's
not the superman the superman is not the ascetic you know nice has
a lot of schopenhauer and
schopenhauer says yes yes you have to be
ascetic said no
no about it is human  not suffer
the not the poorest not the next
and now it's getting exciting but not
the best why not the b  Este one
should think from what we
know from nietzsche so far that the superman
is the one who develops ergo
also the best
and that's not how it's meant but
it's actually about him it's
not about that one
thing is my capital is the  ire is successful
in a company or a politician or
alexander the great conquers the gigantic
empire he is not concerned with the fact that the
best is the superman he says the
higher nature of the great man lies in
the directness
it is interesting applicable
directness not in any
effects whether he too  so
shake the globe the higher nature of the
great man on the way to
becoming a superman does not lie in the fact that he achieves huge effects and shakes the whole
globe but in his
directness yes what does that mean that
someone can be shared with and why should
that be a quality that the  could
not have been understood and
he explains it quite well, well  yes, it
is ultimately about finding our
own inner, higher idea, i.e.
our innermost creative potential of
our higher being, if we find that
then we have to live it and then
it doesn’t matter whether we are understood
and able to communicate then we have to see it
through
and he writes many great
writers and also painters who
had something like that they did their thing
regardless of whether they were
understood for example that is not
by nietzsche himself is an example
but i think van gogh is quite good
who was the catch after all  yes destitute
his whole life and everyone just
shook their heads about his pictures
no one tensed him because he
painted a completely new kind yes it
's true he belongs to the athletes
of expressionism who has when their
kornfeld has seen with such frames
over it and came in a storm he
painted it it's totally terribly sorry he
could is a mood he felt
h  at the way he perceived reality he
put
it on the canvas and
then there was nothing more idyllic about everything
says yes I don't have anything like that hanging on me
yes well he bumped into walls
no one understood this this new way of this
fervent 1 at all
or the sunflowers where he where he there
you can see the sunflowers already beautiful
and great and powerfully vital
but you can already see a few withered
leaves and if you had this whole metamorphosis you could see
that it is also harmful
and the suffering of this flower is
there  something in it but that
was not understood at all at the time
this new realism on the one hand and
on the other hand this direct
way of capturing his feelings only with these dashed
lines over which he painted five times
and you know about
chris who died destitute and today these
pictures are the most expensive paintings on the
all over the world nothing reaches such
prices and then I would say it should
n't matter  play whether we now get the
recognition of the others and
it shouldn't play a role whether we
somehow become ridiculously rich with our actions and what we do
so it is by no means the case that he would say that today
the manager and such and such the
bankers  are anything but
superhuman there he would say look at
me these superfluous riches they
acquire and become poorer so
this inability
so you notice what a dazzling
description he ultimately gives of his
about people and he also
adds that passionate people think
little about it  what the others think your
condition he lifts you above
vanity that's important to
him too of course many come out as himself
because he himself you know
who was even if you will no
one read nietzsche back then
they all had him for  kept a
weirdo and he had his books the
publishers didn't come then his books anymore
then has  he in his desperation
didn't have to kill them until towards the
end of his life but
didn't realize it anymore because he was already
ill it actually
fell on fertile ground but
he experienced it that way too but
that's just a kind of a
sideshow and he says everyone has their
good day where they find a higher
self so that's what
he cares about us finding our higher self yes and he
says everyone has moments like that you should, for
example, see a painter according to his highest
vision and  he
was able to portray appraising and admiring and
not whether he was successful or something, so
it was important to him
that we realize the innermost creative potential
and because we are completely free
and because we are breaking new ground
that is of course
difficult to understand at first and also
obscure  that he describes the superman in
his book zarathustra and
zarathustra is not a conventional
phil  osophical work but that a
poetic work where he served his great
prophet zarathustra who comes at the beginning of the book he comes from the
mountains around and then tells how
the world should look like he
created his own prophet and
this act austria then tells us how he
way to the new person
and so he gives us many
say yes the game is meant more
and as you can see yes he is maybe
more interested in artists and thinkers and
philosophers etc
but i would say he also has a few
other quotes that  show that he is
not only concerned with geniuses
so everyone writes here has their
good day and what I also
find interesting in zarathustra now gives us
another hint that I want to give him at the end
as we are on the way to the
superman  have to
go through three
metamorphoses I'll give you this hint now
three metamorphoses I call
you three metamorphoses of the spirit  the
spirit must of course run as the
spirit becomes a
camel and the camel becomes a lion and finally the lion becomes a child
very famous the parable of nietzsche
so the spirit first becomes a camel
then the camel becomes a lion and in the end
the lion becomes a child exciting  goes
why to the child and with the camel meant
that we are all there now, by the way
, this parable is always about two things:
our individual life
development and the history of
mankind is social at the
moment and individual is the phase of the
camel that we all go through
our training period where we
learn where the parents the mentors the
teachers put more and more burdens on us
so the phase of the camel says there is
the trag sahm tolerant phase that
everyone will go through we do more and more
knowledge on us load more and more morality
more and more laws always  more
patterns of behavior etiquette rules etc that
is the camel phase in our
youth then comes the de phase  s lions in
the phase of the lion we tear everything to shreds
we tear it apart we
free ourselves from the old trauma from the
old traditions and traditions
and what our parents said to
us this is the phase of the lion with
its teeth tearing there  everything is
often interpreted in such a way that for many it
is puberty where one liberates for
some it also happens much later
in adulthood for some it
really only occurs in the midlife crisis it
doesn't matter now let's leave it
aside philo-genetically
meant the phase  of the lion is this
phase where mankind so let's start
with the camel at the beginning we are all
believers and we are, so to speak, in
humility and lifted up in the religious
worldview he then calls this whole long phase
the phase of the camel but with
how should I say with  the lion
there, he didn't
elaborate further, could mean the enlightenment
where we actually
shred and tear everything  eat and question the
beginning of nature in shanghai but
i said we mustn't stop there
we mustn't stop
at the phase of the lion neither as
individuals is enough if we
free ourselves nor many genetically so from
the social situation
and that said then  now the
transformation into the playing child has to
come and there he asks an interesting
question he says this year in a light
as you say pathetic tone the
dentist has he speaks to his
younger ones and to his brothers this
prophet zarathustra is a great book by the way
so that  it's fun
that you read it
and then he says but says my brothers,
what else can the child do that the
lion couldn't get into mine either? so far
it's clear to us
he's the camel's phase then the
lion but why
is this last big metamorphosis  a
transformation into a playing child is
expected from
nietzsche on the way to superman  is the
last transformation into a huge
monster or an almighty dragon
or does the devil know no the last
transformation what can the child do
what the lion could not and he
replies create new values that the l
on cannot creat
but create freedom for yourself to create new thing
can the power of the lion
so the lion can only make room
for us to create something new
but he doesn't set any new values
doesn't create that yet and a
I said most peopl
still manage to fr
e themselves from at some point in their lives  your
upbringing your he comes from things
and all sorts of influences but the
crucial thing is now what do we do
with our freedom what do we do
with it and he says sometimes proves
nothing very sociable nietzsche that he
booked and lived alone
we visited friends signs once
very interesting all tell
always take from what they emancipated
and everything  have freed and what they have finally
left behind but
he is actually more interested in why
not free from what they have freed themselves from everything
but for what how you now
fill out the freedom signs because
i want to hear your ruling thoughts
and not that you have
escaped to one  free of what does the
astra hell bike care about but let me
free your eyes for what and that's what it's about
in this phase of life
we find something for which our own creat
ve potential could so to speak dialy
is us and that's where the trans
ormations the child is important in the playi
g  child and now we
can understand why because in this
phase power of liberation we
basically have to
start from scratch so we basically have
to go back into the world impartially
and then said innocence is the child
and forget to start anew a game
1 council rolling out of itself a first
movement say a holy year to the game
to  games of creation so
says here so the child is innocent
yes that is unbiased and the child
has this holy saying yes to creation
and you know how we as children
and could increase them and
can play passionately
and we have to win that again and he said
not only the really great artists
but of course there is also
a quote from picasso i find that
fits very well at this point picasso also had the
big problem he left even more how
should i put it the whole
tradition by his abstract painting
2000 years  for a long time you painted
things and he suddenly
painted abstractly and i didn't
trust it right away either and picasso once
said you need a very long time
to become young
they are a nice quote which
basically means exactly what he means  tenant
says you need a lot of time
to become young and for
him being young simply meant seeing things the
way you do them, etc  or takes a look and
then he got into this abstraction
and that's not the point that that's why
this third transformation in the
playing child and some say the
years about people meant to me individual
outstanding personalities who come from
time to time but i think it
's allowed to think about it  whether that
can't also apply to us,
yes, and there he says, for example, in
the aphorisms maturity of the man that
means having found the seriousness again that
one had as a child in the game maturity
of
the man means having found the seriousness again that one has  as a child there
was something in the game applies to women of
course just as much maturity of the woman
would also mean that you
find yourself serious again
to set yourself passionately rhine because such a game
to delve into it to lose yourself in it is
about these things these are the
steps  on the way to the higher self
basically what i since i claim this superman
is one big
selfv  realization of the coming out
story that you are telling us guth
and but there is a big obstacle
if we are already thinking about whether that would
also be an option for us nietzsche writes
there is a big obstacle
namely the time when it said all people would
fall apart like at all times  even
now all people are falling apart as in all times so also now into slaves and
free
because whoever does not have two
thirds for himself is a slave no matter
what he wants townsman merchant civil servant
so whoever of
his day grants me at least two  third
insured the café is then safe whether
the minister is or he buys he is
count and i often think to myself ladies
and gentlemen when i come home in the evening
exhausted after somatic no
creative thoughts come up
then you have the tv on and off
and that's it  basically what he says i
fast the human rights
demands since then you really have two thirds of the
day for yourself only then  n can
we actually tap our potential and give it
to society
so that would mean let's
say we get up at 9 well let's say
8 a.m. and sometimes from 8 a.m.
to 8 p.m.
that would be the day we shape
where we are fit where we are awake and there
two thirds that would be twelve
hours there would be two thirds if we don't do the
math correctly
we basically need to
work only four hours a day what
he says here is the four hour day
for example yes  absolutely
the circle will close even more now
because i want
to put an end to it right now, so to speak,
so nietzsche i will summarize god
is dead
new idols capitalism socialism
nationalism what is we must not
offer that would be wrong that only
the small minds who are only capable would do it
to develop any false feelings
instead of developing your own
and we must now
try to decide in reverse  closed to unfold after the death of
god himself we hear
that a higher inner being to
unfold and there never gives us the
two more hints on the one hand it is important
that we become dionysian again,
that means that we live with relish that
we use the
dionysian principle that has been suppressed for centuries  let the creative
Dionysian have their say more, so
to speak, and I'll
tell you what he says, yes, there are
more people who have more shares without themselves
and some who no
longer have napoli shares.
I myself ran a
film school for years and they
musicians and where where difficult people,
yes, my real students, because the
shooters come from their innermost being and
then they are no longer open to criticism,
because that comes up, yes, it is beyond any
criticism with the politicians, yes
, they think logicians with whom you can
discuss, that’s it  arguments that
the musicians are but that's
just an excursus in the end and the mu  of
course the creative ones
have to be like that too, you have to say again
they have to rely on
what they recognized as their innermost but never
the advises us to
actually take our physical
principle into account again on our way our
intuition and secondly what I’m
actually right  I think this picture is nice,
this thought that maybe we
should try to become a
playing child again and so I would like
to close with a quote from him
you still have to have chaos inside you
to be able to give birth to a dancing star
thank you very much
[applause]